قالت اداره الكوارث والطوارئ التركيه
الزلزال الذي تعرضت له البلاد هو اكبر
زلزال في منطقه الاناضول منذ الفي عام
واشارت الى تجاوز طول التصدع الذي حدث
للارض في المناطق المنكوبه 400 كيلو متر
واوضحت اداره الكوارث والطوارئ التركيه ان
هناك حاجه كبيره الى تقديم الدعم النفسي
للمواطنين المتضررين في المناطق المنكوبه
وجددت الدعوه لسكان الا يقتربوا من مناطق
الزلزال اضخمت اعداد المباني الايه للسقوط
من مركز اداره الكوارث والطوارئ التركيه
افاد في انقره ينضم الينا بروفيسور اورهان
تاتار نائب رئيس اداره الكوارث والطوارئ
التركيه لشؤون الزلزال بروفيسور اورهان
مرحبا بك معنا في هذه المرحله
وعند اليوم العاشر من وقوع الزلزال ما هي
اولويات اداره الكوارث والطوارئ التركيه
في حقيقه الامر
كما تعلمون هذه
الزلزله التي واجهناها هي الاكثر
تدميرا في منطقه الاناضول الجغرافيه
على مدى زمن طويل هذا زلزال عظيم جدا واثر
على
[موسيقى]
تقريبا
110 الاف
كيلو متر مربع و13 مليون شخص
تاثروا مباشره بهذا الزلزال ولذلك فان هذه
الاعداد هائله لذلك نحاول ان نجلي الناس
من المناطق التي ضربها الزلزال الى اماكن
اخرى امنه في تركيا وفي الوقت الحاضر قمنا
بنقل ما يقارب من 1.5 مليون شخص من منطقه
الزلزال الى مناطق امنه في تركيا وخاصه
المناطق الساحليه
في منطقه بحر ايجا والبحر المتوسط ومناطق
اخرى في منطقه الاناضول من ناحيه اخرى نحن
نحاول ان نصل الى الناس في المناطق
الريفيه وقد استطعنا الوصول الى كل الناس
في عمومي منطقه
الزلزال وهذا امر مهم وفي الوقت الحاضر
فريقنا الذي يعمله في جهود الانقاذ ما زال
يعمل
ويحصل على اخبار تعتبر
معجزات بعد
هذا الوقت من مرور الزلزال لذلك نحن ما
زلنا ننقذ الناس من المباني المنهاره وسوف
نستمر ببذل اقصى جهودنا للقيام باعمال
البحث والانقاذ في المناطق المنكوبه في
الايام القادمه وهذه نقطه مهمه جدا ايضا
من ناحيه اخرى ان نحاول ان نقوم
بنقل
المواد الاغاثيه الانسانيه والماوى للناس
الكثير من الخيام
قلنا بتوزيعها كما اننا قمنا
بالعمل على استجلاب المزيد منها
لتقديمها للناس هذا امر في غايه الاهميه
ايضا سوف نقوم بالبدء ببناء مباني جديده
منذ بدايه شهر مارس ونحاول ان ننهي ذلك
بحلول نهايه 2023
سيد ارهان
بالنسبه لهذه الكارثه كيف تقيم سيد ارهان
استجابه فرق اداره الكوارث والطوارئ
التركيه
هذه الكارثه التي حدثت خاصه من حيث يعني
كبر حجم المساحه التي حدثت فيها هذه
هذا هذا التدمير حدث في هذا التدمير
وبالنسبه ايضا لعامل الوقت الضاغط والمؤثر
في حياه العالقين
ياس
ياسمه جدا وفي الحقيقه
افاد او اداره الكوارث وحاله الطوارئ تقوم
بالتنسيق بين فرق الانقاذ ولذلك لدينا
فرقنا الخاصه بالبحث والانقاذ الفرق
الاخرى للبحث والانقاذ تقوم بالتنسيق مع
افاد ومن خلال افاد ويدربون من خلال افاد
او رئاسه اداره الكوارث وحالات الطوارئ
ولدينا الان
اكثر من 220 الف شخص يعملون في هذه
المنطقه وعلى الاقل 60 الف من هؤلاء هم
متخصصون بالبحث والانقاذ وهذا يعتبر عددا
كبيرا فيما يخص جهود البحث والانقاذ في
هذه المنطقه ايضا
قمنا
ببنائي الكثير من الخيام للمنكوبين
وايضا
ماوى مؤقت في اماكن كثيره جدا
وايضا حصلنا على دعم دولي مما يقرب من 85
دوله ونحن ممنون لدعمهم لنا في هذه
الاوقات العصيبه التي ضرب فيها الزلزال
هذه المناطق
شكرا جزيلا لك بروفيسور
اورهان نائب رئيس اداره الكوارث وطوارئ
التركيه لشؤون الزلزال حدثنا من افات في
انقره